[Music]
some pretty interesting news right now
going on
australia cancels the visa of novak
djokovic ahead of the 2022 australia
open
where is he from uh
so he can't leave then no this is the
australia open he can't come australia
where is he from originally where is
drogofish from he's from australia what
is djokovic what is that djokovic
uh could be russian could be polish or
some eastern european where is bosnian
joe
kovich from
uh oh serbia serbia there it is serbia
but australia has they're like um
infamous for their visa issues right
across the world super infamous the two
hardest pla three i'm gonna go ahead and
say three i think ryan kennedy says this
three hardest places to get into
straight up
australia canada and the uk yeah if you
don't have the right documentation visa
invitation letter or whatever the [ __ ]
they will
you it doesn't [ __ ] matter who you
are while you're there yeah you're out
your wife's [ __ ] when she's crying
is number four
you know what i mean
you know what's crazy is now there's no
um
border guards at uk
there's no border guards
is that for real
why
no i mean like
it's just machines
so you just scan your passport and you
walk with it
it is hard to get in because also like
when we were touring stuff if someone
had like a dui within the last 10 years
they just couldn't go to canada at all
or you couldn't go to australia at all
yeah be a convicted criminal
we had to leave people behind and like
just get them later because that stuff
yeah so australia has canceled the visa
of serbian tennis player novak djokovic
ahead of the 2022 australian open
and there's a lot of controversy around
this thing because
the country intends to deport him
right and his lawyers are expected to
appeal
and why is controversial because
australia's health minister greg khan
confirmed the news saying that the star
failed to provide quote-unquote
appropriate standards of proof
that would have allowed him to enter the
country okay the australian border force
confirmed the news through a statement
saying the abf will continue to ensure
that those who arrive at our border
comply with our laws and ensure
requirements they can confirm that mr
djokovic failed to provide appropriate
evidence to meet the nature requirements
to australia and his visa has been
subsequently cancelled and this has to
do with the vaccine mandates
now here's the thing
he was
apparently
given pretty much kind of like a free
pass a medical free pass in order to
participate in the 2022 australia open
right so like you hit it so good [ __ ] it
yeah
but he was you know quote unquote
granted this free pass
but when he actually got there to border
control because he had
failed to provide adequate evidence
it's not only that they didn't allow him
in except they detained him
for many many hours interrogated him
and and are now about to deport him when
he was already given said pass so it's
this weird so it's like different
departments arguing and saying like you
could come in and then the border
control is like nah you can't did he
couldn't provide evidence of the past
itself oh no
it's it's a little unclear of the
specifics of that detail but ultimately
yeah and and it's not just so much that
he didn't provide it and they sent him
home and deported him it's that they
detained him for many many hours
interrogated him that's kind of what
they do at the border control though
that [ __ ] happened to hannah yeah yeah
what happened to my mom too
wait in australia no in the us how so
what happened um because when she
re-entered
uh they were like what are you doing
here whatever whatever like they're just
hassling her and you get randomly picked
for [ __ ] like that even if you're here
legitimately and that's what sucks and
what people don't really talk about is
like
if border control wants to even if you
have the right visas even if you have
whatever
if they feel like
i just want to [ __ ] around with you for
a minute they'll pull you in and then
they'll basically she wasn't able to use
the bathroom or
you know get a snack or drink water or
nothing like they just they they were
trying to take her phone and get into
her pictures and all this stuff and like
when you're not on the u.s citizen
the same rules do not apply to you they
do some illegal [ __ ] and then if you
call them out on it they'll try to
backtrack or say no this is legal we can
do that we could kick you back to
wherever you came from [ __ ] mean dude
it's like welcome to america you're a
criminal
until you're proven innocent so it's a
completely different process and i'm
sure like
you know they all have their reasons
trying to protect their country or
whatever it is but it's just like
mind-blowing that something like that
can happen in the states
so djokovic is actually a nine-time
winner and he's um he's not really
spoken publicly about his vaccination
status but last year he said he was
opposed to vaccination and it actually
remains unclear what qualifies this 34
year old for exemption because he got a
medical exemption for it but the
tournament director
said it would be helpful helpful for
jokefish to clarify his situation so the
australia opened his schedule beginning
on 17th of january but
they're pretty much revealing that the
26 unvaccinated players who applied for
exemption
djokovic was only among a handful of
them given the green light under
guidelines set by figure the federal
regulator so he was literally given a
medical exemption therefore he decided
to go
but at border control that didn't
[ __ ] matter because he couldn't quote
unquote provide that so yeah in the
similar
it's like
when you [ __ ] get stopped at border
control it's not like uh it doesn't make
sense separate it doesn't always make
sense it's it's like it's like prison
it's like when my wife's been crying i'm
like trying to get into it and i'm like
you know no entry none of this makes
sense i'm like okay cool so you made it
seem like we're cool but then now we're
not and then crying and you guys even
married me wet up here and not wet down
there and i'm like okay cool so i guess
we're not [ __ ] but you want to do but
then like now i got to hear about your
whole [ __ ] day
damn
it sucks man i didn't sign up for it you
didn't sign up for that
obviously people uh on social media are
going crazy because this guy's [ __ ] a
celebrity in the star right yeah people
are saying things like
you know even people are tweeting like
i'm no fan of novak djokovic and
skeptical of the process that granted
him a medical exemption but the fact is
he now has the exemption so there are no
grounds to cancel his visa it's an
appalling way to treat anyone australia
looks like a backward backwater but
australia does they have been changing
their their uh mandates to be a lot
stricter so i'm sure like if they just
change something
it's like [ __ ] your whatever pass you
got yeah but it can't you know but the
past came from austria can he call
whoever gave him the pass like a higher
up like like hey [ __ ] i don't know
like nbc dude you know like was the past
through the tournament
or was it through the state it sounds
like an official it mentioned that it
was a federal medical exemption but the
thing that made the caveat if you will
is that he didn't he wasn't able to
provide all the evidence that supported
the example that's probably a nebulous
phrase that they gave him maybe they
emailed him a pdf he didn't print that
[ __ ] out you know that's his fault be
prepared you know
athlete that's like all the people that
that fly to hawaii and then they get
surprised they got a quarantine and it's
like you didn't [ __ ] upload your
vaccine card you [ __ ] take your
goddamn [ __ ] pcr test it's very
simple fire your assistant you [ __ ]
idiot fire your assistant you have all
the money in the world what are you
doing there's a bad liaison somewhere in
this story when this [ __ ] happened to me
was it first and last name huh what all
right
i don't remember
because he fired her i was like you're
fine
to be fair and to be correct joe what
joe's saying is right if
you don't provide the appropriate
documentation like that's on you you
know what i'm saying and i remember this
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] happened to me
in australia when we went when we went
you remember the ticket tour you
remember we were the notorious [ __ ]
story group me and lawrence cows
specifically who nearly got deported
i don't know because we were busy
getting scolded for an orange and a
backpack yeah so yeah and you and
anthony checked in some weird costumes
yeah yes because you're working you're
working yeah we were all there for the
tour but we were so [ __ ] dumb
ignorant naive that we didn't know that
we were
either in the right to say that we were
there working because we thought that
was inappropriate so we thought that it
would be
smarter to
hide behind the veil that we were
touring the country we just happened to
be tourists we were there not for
business we were there for pleasure
however when they were skeptical they
decided to check our stuff and the
reason why me and lawrence count
specifically lawrence cowell lawrence
cowell
kl the reason why
we were even skeptical we weren't sure
is because we didn't receive the
documentation or the letter of record um
of your visa work visa yeah work visa
and there's there's like a letter that
you need to present as well like an
invitation letter right you had to have
like a number of different documentation
but we didn't receive that documentation
so
we were like [ __ ] we should uh
maybe we should like come up with an
excuse and so we're on the same page
because we had [ __ ] tiger onesie
costumes in our suitcases for the show
it was a it was a funny bit that we did
you guys know what i remember at the
tick tick tour right but
we're like we should say that we're uh
we're here for a wedding nobody's gonna
[ __ ] get mad we're here for a wedding
and uh why do we have the suits uh we're
we're performing at the wedding yeah
yeah we'll stick to that story then we
[ __ ] get called into the
interrogation room and stuff like what
are you guys doing here but oh we're
performing for a wedding they start
going through our suitcases and you know
they start swabbing for like drug
residue around yeah they [ __ ]
apparently found like five counts of
like heroin or random [ __ ] all over
random stuff and we never [ __ ] did
that stuff we did a bunch of other drugs
but not heroin right so they're like no
you for sure have some stuff on you
we're like no officer like we swear
we're just here for the wedding and
dumbasses and us try to stay and stick
to our our lie
right this should win the dumbest
livestream
um and and so they kept on pressing us
we were stuck in there for like two and
a half hours all the way to the point
after they searched everything where
they're like we're going to take you to
the hospital right now because we need
to x-ray you and check you for um
they're going to probe your problems
because we they thought that we shoved
drugs up our ass holy [ __ ] and i
literally told the guy i literally told
the guy i was like i will i was [ __ ] in
a bowl here right now to show you that
we are not drug dealers we swear we're
not trying to do that we're just trying
to get into the blah blah right and then
finally after so much time me and me and
lawrence was sitting there like [ __ ] in
the bowl we should tell the truth
all right we got after they're about to
take us to the hospital with police
right we're like we gotta tell you the
truth man
we're not drug dealers
we're here to perform
we're gonna perform at a show we're not
here performing for a wedding we just
were scared because we didn't have the
right paperwork
and then he literally said he's like if
you would have told me the truth i would
have let you in but you guys are idiots
and now i gotta you know deport you blah
blah so they send us to the next
department people like to this other
back room where they take our [ __ ]
they're about to take our phone and
right when they're about to take our
phone is when uh ty the the promoter
calls
right and we're again we're in like a
detention area so i'm not supposed to
pick up my phone but like i [ __ ] pick
up my phone because i was like oh my god
i need to fix the [ __ ] and he's like yo
what's going on i was like yo you got to
give us a paperwork and they're like get
off the phone get off the phone right
now i was like you gotta talk to this
guy i can't talk to you right now i'm
hanging up to call back so i hang up on
him
and then i literally i'm begging them to
just talk to this promoter he'll explain
everything literally one of the guys is
finally down to be nice he's all right
fine he talks to the promoter he's gone
for 20 minutes while me and lawrence are
literally in there sweating the balls
and we're like we're going to get sent
home there's going to suck balls right
the guy finally comes back and i talked
to your guy and it's all good we got the
information you're clear to go wow man
that's why you should always tell the
truth
it was the stupidest thing we [ __ ]
lied about being performers at a wedding
with some [ __ ] but point is australia is
really really difficult don't [ __ ]
lie about that [ __ ] and it doesn't
matter who you are if you're a [ __ ]
18 time champion or whatever
you have to have the right documentation
i heard lawrence had a deep throat a
banana on camera for that guy yeah he
did to get to get you guys in that's
what i showed him his performance skills
hey you're a performer aren't you
[Music]
[Music]
you